hi I'm Edward I'm studying physics and I
was wondering what this the escape
velocity if the Milky Way is Edward
you'd like to know what is the escape
velocity of the Milky Way this actually
is not very well known because we don't
know how massive the Milky Way is but we
have seen a few stars that come flying
out of the center and they seem to be
going fast enough to get out when a
binary star encounters the black hole in
the middle of the galaxy it's possible
for for the one of them to get such a
kick that it comes out at a thousand
kilometers per second which is about
five times the orbital velocity of the
Sun around the center so maybe a
thousand kilometers per second is the
escape velocity but it's not measured